but one of the things when you talk
about your anxiety and the people that
i've seen
speak to you is it makes me feel less
alone
it's and especially these days where
everybody feels isolated we all feel
isolated before
in our own heads and said so well you
know i think of you as someone who
again i i'm just not that guy
but when i feel like you know tom
doesn't need anything tom doesn't need
anyone he needs
he has his wife and he has his child but
before that tom just
either you didn't let anybody into that
because you are a private guy and i
appreciate you always to open up
whatever you want to open up and you
know i'm always uh
happy when you just talk to me but
ultimately
you know you hold a lot in i'm sure but
you go you know you're kind of like you
do something you go home you don't need
anybody you don't need to be around a
lot of people
and do you get lonely do you feel
sometimes lonely even though you have a
kid a child you ever feel like
i'm i'm still alone in a way sometimes i
think there's been times i think
like when we were doing smallville there
was a lot of loneliness because i didn't
know how to navigate that
and maybe i kind of kept everybody away
because
i just i wanted to be alone because one
i didn't have any time alone
during those years and your ex wasn't
that supportive not to bring her up
i don't know i mean like i don't i don't
know how you go further than
non-supportive whatever that word is
i noticed that i just always remember
like you know a woman
or a man needs to they just need to
support each other
and like you're if you're in a
relationship you want support and if
you're single i mean like you are you
have a
you have a great support system around
you with your friends and your family
but
support is very important um
but i listen i mean i don't mind being
by myself i
mean everybody needs time to themselves
um as you know i just moved
and got some more space up in northern
california and
at least for an hour a day i go outside
and i'm up in the hills in the mountains
and by myself and that's
it's like a i don't see it as an act of
meditation but it probably is it just
gets me out yeah one thing